homie Huey I mean I've I've talked about
my fair share of being idiot off of road
rage it's such stupid embarrassing [ __ ]
now that I think about it but I have we
I remember my boy [ __ ] this was so
bad so this dude is driving like a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
basically my buddy the time he owned the
RSX Type S and dude I had a similar car
as a few years older my buddies this was
pretty [ __ ] quick and so he I
remember he dusted this Porsche and like
the porsche owner was like he couldn't
[ __ ] believe it
he got torched by a [ __ ] honda anyway
so we're on the freeway FYI like Burbank
and this [ __ ] is this dude is just on
our ass and my buddy had just had it
like you usually let him do his thing
my buddy's like all right bro you want
to ride my ass I'm like this is about to
be bad all right bro y'all ride my ass
as a I'm gonna ride my [ __ ] ass hi
bro you're trying to ride my ass then
ride my ass all right pull that dick out
get ready for a [ __ ] good ride you
want to ride my throbbing juicy ass
cheeks that what you want
would've been tough as hell we just
slammed the brakes and got in like a
[ __ ] 40 car yeah oh you want to ride
my ass and then got out and Munda yeah I
would have been doh what it was so dope
if while driving just a pair of ass
cheeks came out the sunroof dudes like
wait how and it's just my buddy driving
still feet on the pedals ass in the air
no hands on the pedals yeah there you go
yeah hands on the pedals driving with
his teeth driving literally teeth and
ass she has cheeks out the thing yeah
and legs actually he's working he's
upside down he's upside down so his ass
is facing the wrong way actually the
windier
that's the new mooning yeah his flat
full-frontal flashing okay just here's
my dick man yeah oh here's my vagina man
he's mine whoa whoa
flashing vagina is not offensive though
yeah but it's still like oh oh yeah but
now dicks are ugly though dicks are like
I understand why like if a woman pees in
public it's not you know mmm it's it's
just it's not really that gross to me a
woman peeing in public not really really
yeah it's never like but that's never
like a graceful thing I mean girls will
say is - you know like squat down in the
[ __ ] and then it's not squatting down
behind a truck or something it's not
graceful but like peeing in public with
a dick just it's got like a certain
aggression to it you know I'm saying you
can point it at something and that's why
I think it makes it indecent you know
I'm saying but the woman likes just to
get down and it's like it's like a it's
a it's going in a specific area you know
a woman can't necessarily point her piss
not at all but that's what makes it less
graceful no I would say cuz it's going
everywhere and it's just on the ground
you know it's like a puppy takes a piss
that's going all over the floor maybe
its feet but still cute yeah with a man
it's like it can be threat you know I'm
saying yeah you can use it as like a
weapon yeah yeah yeah man can beep is
like a picture put that away and he's
like oh yeah always like it was like it
let's think about what we're gonna do
here starts peeing all over your
cardigan eyes to piss yeah just over
your [ __ ] t-shirt yeah what were you
saying
what were you saying put what away
[ __ ] I condemn the weaponization
of piss there we go
that's our [ __ ] that's our platform I
condemn 2020 mm-hmm so this was [ __ ]
my my buddy he's like all right man you
want to ride my ass dude ride this ass
he [ __ ] you know she drops like two
gears and it's [ __ ] we just ribs like
ah and like we come from like I don't
know 72 like some stupid number like 95
and like a couple seconds
and I grabbed the oh [ __ ] handle and I
and I just like this is the most casual
I've been in a situation where we could
have definitely died cuz it wasn't like
a free-flowing freeway it was like busy
I said bro I don't really think this is
worth it and then this dude he like he
goes out like three lanes he to catch up
it takes and why I don't know he like
wants to race that's wise I don't know
that's a lame as [ __ ] ever so here's
where it gets ultra lame who gives a
[ __ ] so this kid he speeds up and he and
he gets like one lane next to us and he
turns on his [ __ ] cabin light and he
starts like throwing gang signs at us
and my buddy just this enraged him this
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] at sign
language he was doing yeah he's like
stacking or whatever and he's feeling
real tough and my boys like he was like
oh you're in a [ __ ] gang you're in a
[ __ ] gang and he's just goes [ __ ] you
man and and then the dude cuts in front
of us and like slams his brakes
so then we slow down and then then the
dude speeds up he like gets us to go
slow and he takes off and he does that
because it was his exit so my buddy
follows him and I said okay well again I
said amen
we might win right now but we don't know
what's coming next
my buddy's like nah [ __ ] that and we
follow him off the freeway we make a
couple Rights and we're at a stoplight
this dude is he abruptly cuts into a
left turn lane and he bolts into like a
neighborhood and it's like hella dark
and my buddy like turns on his blinker
and I said bro and head and I just like
I remember looking at real cold and he
just like you like undoes the thing and
he's like [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm like what
are we gonna do jump out the car [ __ ]
him up because he wanted to ride your
ass well then what nobody rides my oh
yeah exactly
exactly and then we just like so you
want to talk about winning you know who
wanted that scenario
he did because within seconds of not
going like into the [ __ ] neighborhood
some cop had heard my buddy come off the
freeway and he gave him [ __ ] fix-it
ticket for his exhaust yeah wait your
buddy yeah he heard us like coming down
the freeway and the other dudes car was
like slow and quiet my buddy's car is
like loud and fast so like as soon as we
got off and the dude made the left turn
in the neighborhood we were sitting
there the cops like and he lights us up
and my buddy gets a ticket so the other
dude one for sure yeah yeah yeah beasted
us Jesus yeah that's crazy man I mean I
guess that's you know so riding ass is
all about right now you can ride my
Reagan ass here is your buddy's ass and
then he got away with it and one rode
the [ __ ] out of there
[Music]